[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une réalité que nous
vivons depuis maintenant 15 jours à la
fois parce que nous accompagnons des
personnes âgées qui sont à leur domicile
elles sont près de 30000 en france et
puis nous accompagnons aussi des ehpad
donc des résidences services des
résidences seniors où nos solutions sont
présentées vous là aussi on accompagne à
la fois on assiste les soignants est à
la fois aux gère la relation avec les
familles donc vous savez tous
aujourd'hui dans la situation dans
laquelle nous vivons tous
c'est une population qui est très
fragilisée et qui est surtout en
souffrance on a mis en place toute une
série de process dents au sein de notre
entreprise une partie des collaborateurs
travaillent en télétravail et on a
laissé cette plateforme fonctionner
depuis saint quentin en yvelines pour
être certain que nous ayons la bonne
réactivité et les bons retours donc nous
sommes très beau jour d'hui très
sollicité les personnes âgées que nous
accompagnons ont des boutons d'appel
chez eux ont des détecteurs de chute et
ils peuvent les manipuler à tout moment
souvent lorsqu'ils se sentent surtout
seul et puis il ya aussi de plus en plus
de d'actions qui sont on doit appeler ou
les voisins ou les services de secours
et sur ses services de secours ils sont
très mobilisés aujourd'hui sur coville
donc il faut qu'on soit le plus efficace
possible auprès de leurs services pour
avoir les bons mots les bonnes
terminologie et puis qu'on puisse ainsi
apporter le maximum de soutien aux
familles
en attendant et en ayant quelques
échanges avec des directeurs
d'établissements aujourd'hui leur
quotidien c'est quoi des centres
d'hébergement de qui accueille des
personnes en situation de handicap ou
des centres de type ehpad résidence
seniors les ans autonomie qui
accueillent des personnes âgées
ils sont totalement noyé pour alors
quotidien il faut qu'ils gèrent les
équipements qu'ils gèrent les familles
fois qu'ils gèrent leurs résidents et on
a eu une idée comme on a une plateforme
avec aujourd'hui des écoutes en décharge
et d'écouté d'assistance on s'est dit
qu'on pourrait aussi assister ces
personnes ces soignants en étant là
présent et 11 ans quelque part la
coordination on a aussi eu une idée
c'est de pourquoi pas à contacter les
restaurateurs qui son retour de certains
ehpad et de leur dire si vous avez des
invendus ou si vous avez quelques
repassions qui sont encore disponibles
bah écoute et à les livrer à l'ehpad d'à
côté il ya une équipe qui travaille
toute la nuit qui sera très contente et
qui va adorer recevoir ça et ça serait
une preuve de reconnaissance